>> NO.
BUT NEXT TIME.
ANOTHER RUSSIA BOMBSHELL
EXPLODING IN THE MEDIA.
WHAT O'DONNELL SAID ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FINANCES ON
HIS SHOW LAST NIGHT.
>> THIS IS A SINGLE SOURCE.
>> OKAY.
>> WHO HAS TOLD ME THAT THE
DEUTSCH BANK OBTAINED TAX
RETURNS WHICH THEY DO HAVE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
SHOW THAT THE PRESIDENT PAYS
VERY LITTLE INCOME TAX.
THIS SINGLE SOURCE CLOSE TO THE
DEUTSCH BANK TOLD ME THAT DONALD
TRUMP LOAN DOCUMENTS THERE SHOW
THAT HE HAS CO-SIGNERS.
THAT'S HOW HE WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN
THOSE LOANS.
THAT THE CO-SIGNERS ARE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS.
>> REALLY?
>> THAT WOULD EXPLAIN EVERY KIND
WORD DONALD TRUMP HAS EVER SAID
ABOUT RUSSIA AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
IN TRUE.
I TRESS THE IF TRUE.
>> WOW.
RACHAEL'S FACE SAID IT ALL.
AFTER BEING RIDICULED ABOUT HIS
FLIMSY REPORTING BY HIS OWN
CO-WORKERS AT MINNEAPOLIS.
MSNBC.
HE TWEETED -- A
>> I WAS WRONG TO DISCUSS THAT
ON THE AIR.
I WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE
TONIGHT.
DANA?
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
WATCH HIS SHOW TONIGHT.
HE HAS ALREADY SHOWN HE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT GIVING ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
I SAY THIS ON TWITTER TOO:
IF YOU HAVE TO WRITE IF TRUE ON
SOMETHING YOU ARE RE-TWEETING
DON'T TWEET IT.
WAIT AND SEE IF IT'S ACTUALLY
TRUE.
>> THAT'S BORING.
>> IT IS BORING!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S WHY YOU WATCH "THE
FIVE" WHERE WE HAVE ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
I UNDERSTAND MISTAKES CAN
HAPPEN.
HE WALKS ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
LINE AND RACHAEL IS, WHAT,
REALLY?
SHE SAID SHE HAD THE PRESIDENT'S
TAX RETURNS AND YOU WAITED FOR
HER FOR 20 MINUTES TO GET TO THE
POINT.
THE RUSSIAN STORY FIZZLED AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO BRING IT
BACK.
BUT YOU BETTER BE READY.
NOW WHAT HAPPENS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAY HERE THEY
GO AGAIN.
I TOLD YOU.
THEY ARE PROVING HIS POINT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
>> IS IT A MISTAKE?
WHEN YOU SAY FURTHER AND YOU SAY
FARTHER?
>> IT'S HARD FOR ME TO JUDGE
BECAUSE I HAVE NEVER MADE A
MISTAKE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ON THIS SHOW I AM BATTING
1,000.
>> I AM THE UMPIRE?
>> YES.
>> YOU WOULD THINK THAT MSNBC
WOULD BE LEERY OF ANY RUSSIAN
BOMBSHELL STORY.
THEY PUT EVERYTHING ON RED FOR 3
YEARS AND THEY LOST THE HOUSE.
HERE'S THE THEORY:
MAYBE HE GOT PRANKED.
THE SINGLELE SOURCE COULD HAVE
BEEN TRUMP ON THE PHONE SAYING
YES, IT WAS RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS.
TRUST ME ON THIS, TRUST ME!
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT REMINDS ME OF THAT THING
ON TWITTER.
THE TICK, TICK, TICK.
EVERYBODY PROMISING A BOMBSHELL.
IT'S ALL COMING UP TODAY.
THE VIEWERS MUST GET EXHAUSTED
BEING PROMISED BOMBSHELL AFTER
BOMBSHELL.
WE DON'T PROMISE BOMBSHELL.
WE PROMISE GOOD, HEALTHY, CLEAN
FUN.
>> WHAT IS YOUR TAKE, JUAN?
>> WELL, IT SEEMS WE HAVE GONE
AWAY FROM GATE KEEPERS IN
JOURNAL.
SOCIAL MEDIA IS LIKE WHO HAS IT
FIRST?
WHO CAN JUST MAKE AN OUTRAGEOUS
STATEMENT?
THIS WAS AN OUTRAGEOUS STATEMENT
BY HIS OWN ADMISSION.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE STORY.
NO JOURNALIST IN AMERICA WOULD
SAY A SINGLE SOURCE AND YOU HAVE
NOT GONE TO YOUR EDITORS AND
NOBODY VETTED THIS STORY.
WHAT DO WE HAVE FROM OTHER
PEOPLE?
NOTHING LIKE THAT.
HE JUST MAKES THE STATEMENT.
HE GOT IT WRONG.
IT'S INTERESTING.
SAYING HE MADE AN ERROR IN
REPORTING THIS, HE IS NOT SAYING
THE STORY IS WRONG; HE IS SAYING
HE IS WRONG.
TO ME IT COMES BACK TO SOCIAL
MEDIA WHERE PEOPLE HAVE
CONFIRMATION BIAS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY TAKE
STORIES THEY WANT TO BE TRUE AND
THEN THEY SAY, I WILL BELIEVE
THIS STORY.
I WON'T CHECK IT OUT BECAUSE
THAT MIGHT GET IN THE WAY OF MY
GOOD FEELINGS.
I WILL JUST REPORT IT.
THAT ENDS UP WITH EGG ON YOUR
FACE.
IT'S BAD JOURNALISM.
IN THIS ERA WITH THE INTERNET
DOMINATING EVERYTHING, THIS IS
THE WAY WE ARE GOING.
PEOPLE, THIS IS A MISTAKE.
IT'S NOT GOOD.
>> THAT'S THE POINT THAT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY MADE:
WHEN YOU GO OFF A SINGLE SOURCE,
IT'S RECKLESS.
THOSE RECORDS WERE ON LINE.
HE SAID BECAUSE IT WAS SO
RECKLESS AND HE IGNORED ANY
VERIFICATION OUT, THIS RISES TO
THE LEVEL OF ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE.
THIS HAS OTHER REPURCUSSIONS.
THE HOUSE FINANCIAL COMMITTEE IS
INVESTIGATING TRUMP AND DEUTSCH
BANK.
THEY ARE LAYING OFF 18,000
WORKERS AND BEING INVESTIGATED
FOR OTHER REASONS.
WHEN WE BRING IN OTHER ENTITIES
FROM THESE RECKLESS COMMENTS,
IT'S A RIPPLE EFFECT.
JOURNALISTS HAVE TO BE MORE
AWARE AND IN OWNERSHIP OF WHAT
THEY PUT OUT THERE.
NOT JUST MY BAD.
I RETRACT.
THERE ARE REAL CONQUENCES.
>> EVEN IF HE SAID I AM NOT A
JOURNALIST.
BUT HE DIDN'T PRESENT IT AS HIS
OPINION.
>> AS A JOURNALIST I AM UPSET.
>> THE WORST THING THE STORYOO
ON BOTH SIDES ARE DOING THIS --
SO AND SO SPARKS OUT RAGE.
THEY USE HIS TWEETS.
THEY FIND 3 TWEETS AND THAT'S
THE STORY.
IT'S
WHAT A WASTE OF TIME AND ANGER.
>> IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS HIS LAWYERS
THREATEN O'DONNELL OVER THIS.
HOW OFTEN HAVE YOU SEEN A STORY
FROM DONALD TRUMP AND YOU THINK
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE OF THAT?
>> HE NEVER LIED.
>> NEVER?
>> NOT ONCE!
HE IS DIRECTIONALLY TRUE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU HAVE A 1,000 BATTING
AVERAGE.
WHAT IS HIS?
>> 1,020.